ce que je constate depuis trois ans
c'est que le handicap n'est pas une
véritable ambition pour ce gouvernement
lorsqu'on a encore plus de quinze mille
enfants qui sont sans solution dans
notre pays c'est qu'on n'a pas fait
notre révolution et je voyais parmi les
annonces 'l'annonce d'un numéro de
téléphone
enfin oui unique très bien mais les
parents ils n'ont pas besoin d'un énième
numéro de téléphone unique sur ce sujet
comme sur beaucoup d'autres on est
frappé de ce syndrome du crocodile et
emmanuel macron notamment on a une
grande bouche et on a des petits bras et
donc à jean la période régulière on
revient sur cette question du handicap
mais les actes sont d'une faiblesse
accablante est coupable